[Sarah Richards:] Walter's going to narrate the film as we play it.
[Walter:] The first pictures start out at the power plant.
It's some of the buildings connected to the laundry building.
This is an aerial view from the top of the mountain of the whole camp.
This is another view taken, an aerial view, it's some of the Dixon cottages.
Cottages and the chapel in the background... these were designed by Dr. Dixon.
[Sarah Richards:] Who was Dr. Dixon?
[Walter:] He was, Dr. Dixon was the first Director of Health, Pennsylvania.
This is more aerial view of the surrounding mountains, shows the background of this whole area.
This section is the golf course, which was built by the Health Department.
[Sarah Richards:] Was the golf course for patients?
[Walter:] Staff. The golf course was for staff and employees.
This is still more of an aerial view.
This is a closer picture of the golf course area.
These pictures were taken from Snowy Mountain Fire Tower, which would be south of the sanatorium.
That picture was of the cemetery.
[Sarah Richards:] Is this where patients were buried?
[Walter:] Patients were buried here.
This is the Children's Hospital.
It was originally for patients that were too sick to be out taking care of themselves.
Then, during World War I up until 1923,
it was filled by veterans of World War I that had been gassed in the service.
Then in 1924, why the children were moved in.
[Sarah Richards:] What is this building?
That building was the infirmary.
These are open-air pavilions on the main hospital grounds.
Beside all these cottages, there was 56 of these type of cottages,
they decided to make most of these cottages with open-air pavilions
with chairs that the patients sat in for hours and hours.
[Sarah Richards:] Were the cottages heated?
[Walter:] The cottages had steam heat in the center aisle of the cottage in the hallway.
There wasn't any heat in the rooms unless you had the door open.
This is nurses from the nurses' training.
It ran from 1924 to 1935.
They had a two-year training course for nurses to be trained for TB patients.
This is the store that's on the main grounds, where supplies could be,
newspapers, anything along that line, if they need stationery,
anything along that line could be bought at this store.
[Sarah Richards:] For the patients?
[Walter:] For the patients.
This is the chapel built in 1911.
[Coughing]
This was the original, one of the first nurses' home buildings.
Later on it was used as office buildings.
This was the first large dining room.
These are all patients that are bathing in the sun, fresh air, and sunlight.
[Sarah Richards:] Were male and females segregated?
[Walter:] Yes, there was what they call an upper and lower men's camp,
and an upper and lower women's camp.
There were different sections ...
[Sarah Richards:] What is that man doing there?
[Walter:] He is probably a, uh, either a doctor or an aide that's just supervising,
makes sure that everybody is getting sun, and keeping order. [laughs]
They examined the patients regular.
They would be out and ... and doctors would examine them to make sure
that everything that was possible at that time could be done for them.
These patients are holding mirrors with the sunlight at their back shining in the mirror,
and the light goes into their mouth so it's a way that they felt would cure their throats...
heal up their throats with the sunlight.
This was the assembly building, had been used for a theater.
It was the theater, and also there was a school, a business training school and that building had burnt.
And about two years later there was a new building, um, to replace that one.
And there was a lot of deer in the area, and some of them would get tame, come right in around the cottages.
This would be at the Mont Alto train station, would be about five miles from here, at the foot of the mountain.
These are children that they'd bring in here in the summer,
mostly from the cities, they were called Fresh Air children.
And they would stay in a building back of the Children's Hospital,
it was a long building back of the Children's Hospital, screened on the sides,
and they would stay there for the summer months.
And they just, ah, they felt that the fresh air, and the good food would be a help for them.
Everybody was brought up in trucks from the train station to the top of the mountain.
Then the children were all examined when they come in,
checked for any diseases, so that they wouldn't start a epidemic for the whole area.
Everybody was tested.
They received a few shots which they didn't care for.
All of these tests were made before these children were put in with any of the other, any of the other children.
Everybody received a complete haircut.
[Sarah Richards:] What was they reason for the haircuts?
[Walter:] The haircut was because some of the children had head lice when they came, or other skin diseases,
and they could check for this and treat it immediately and.....
This was in the bath houses.
Everybody had their own toothbrush that they kept with them,
and there was a, there were containers that had tooth powder,
you just went to the container and put powder on your brush and...
[Sarah Richards:] There was one container for everyone?
[Walter:] There would be containers, there'd probably be a dozen of these containers in each bath house.
You just held the brush underneath and you pushed a button and the powder come down onto the brush.
And here they are just examining the children, looking to see what condition they are in.
[Sarah Richards:] Were the clothes the children wear supplied by the center?
[Walter:] All clothing except your shoes were, and socks were supplied by the state.
All clothing were supplied ...
you bought your own shoes and you ah, if you had any repair on your shoes why that uh,
you had to pay for the repair of your shoes and your own stockings.
Everything else was supplied by the state.
You paid for your own haircuts and your shoe repair.
Some of these children were very thin when they came.
But with the food and the fresh air here, it did have a way of fattening you up pretty quick.
This is the, it was twice a day, this was milk in the cans.
One of the men from the dining room would bring out the milk.
You went through, you picked up your cup, filled it, and then there was a container you put the cups in,
and they were taken back, and they would be washed,
and they would be ready for the next time the milk cart came around.
Milk was bought by the state from local farmers in this area.
They had their own pasturizing plant there, and of course, all the milk was in refrigeration, and it was cool.
These are the children sunbathing and a cloth over their faces
was just to keep the sun out of their face and their eyes.
They would lay for so long one way and then they would turn.
You gradually got a suntan without getting sunburnt.
Nurses, doctors would watch...
some people burned much easier than others,
some could only be out a short time.
There was a lot of swings, see-saws, sliding boards, and  this building was located on a hill,
and in the wintertime, there were probably two hundred sleds there for sliding.
But you were out everyday unless you were real sick, real bad cold or something, you were out every day.
This is the room, in one of the rooms, and everybody makes their own bed, and they are ready for inspection.
The nurses and the doctors come through, check everyone.
If anyones feels bad that day, this is when you tell them and you're taken into the clinic.
They check the hands, the fingernails, they make sure you've washed, make sure
you have your hands clean, they check your beds to make sure the bed is made properly.
There's probably 20 beds to a ward.
Did you notice, the children all saluted when the doctor and the nurse left and when they enter?
In this building, the boys were all on the second floor, and the girls were on the first floor.
And at the north end of this building was an auditorium
which was used for a chapel, for a theater, anything of that type.
On the second floor was classrooms.
These children were all still in school.
You went to school a half-day four days, or five days a week, a half-day at a time.
You had practically the same classes you would have had at schools at home.
These are more tests that's given regular to make sure that everyone is okay.
Besides all the swings and the playground equipment,
there was Boy Scouts, Girl Scouts, there was movies and religious services every weekend.
One of the punishments if you didn't do everything that you were expected to do, or if you were a troublemaker,
one of your punishments was you didn't get to go to the Saturday afternoon movie.
You had to stay in bed while the movie was on.
That seemed to be harder on most people than most any other punishment they received.
Another thing for the girls was sewing classes.
The were taught to make their own clothing for doll babies.
There was a lot of organizations brought toys and doll babies
and all kinds of toys at Christmas time that was given out to all.
Everybody received a prize.
There was a lot of games brought in by different organizations.
Games that you had to play, marbles was another,
a lot of marbles, everything along that line was furnished by different organizations.
And this was every evening, everyone had their temperature taken,
And that was recorded.
This was in the area of the sick, sicker wards;
it wasn't so much so in the other part of the hospital.
The hospital would hold 240 patients, and most of the time it was filled.
It started in 19 ...
the first children came in from Hamburg, Pennsylvania in 1924.
That was mostly a way to settle arguments, you got a chance to put the boxing gloves on.
But they made sure no one got hurt too bad.
Even the girls liked the boxing gloves.
This is more in the playground area.
[Sarah Richards:] And these are all still the Fresh Air kids,
none of the real, none of the children who had tuberculosis?
[Walter:] No, there isn't any tuberculosis children in this, in this area.
Now, there was children in the main Children's Hospital that would be there for maybe a couple of years,
two or three years 'til they got better,
but what they called the Fresh Air children were only brought in through the summer months,
they'd be here about three months, and then they went back.
If some of them were real bad, then they would be kept in the main hospital,
they would stay until they were able to go home.
This hospital right here was closed in January 1940.
At that time they were moved closer to the main hospital,
into a new building which had been built in 1938-39.
And later here's why this building was completely torn down.
[Sarah Richards:] The pool was inside.
[Walter:] Yes, these were inside pools.
In 1936, there was another section built to this building for polio patients.
And they had, ah, hot baths, massage tables, like that in there for the polio children.
But from the...
Children moved from this building to the new building in 1940.
The polio ward was moved somewhere else.
I don't know where it was moved to, but those children didn't come over to the new building.
'Course everybody preferred the old building over the new.
We were watched too closely in the new building. [laughs]
We had more fun at the other place.
[Sarah Richards:] So you were there during that transition?
[Walter:] Yes, I was there. I moved into the new building.
They did put, put weight on you with extra good meals and health and everything.
When I came here I weighed 76 lbs, when I left I weighed 114.
Now this is in the winter, the sliding area.
You could slide for a long distance down that ...
there were a few trees you had to watch, but there was a long distance you could slide,
clear down, well it's all grown up now,
but you could go clear down to the main road at the hospital.
But regardless of the weather, you were out every day.
You did bring your own topcoats.
That was one thing, you furnished your own topcoat.
There were many snowball battles.
From the classrooms, which were above the auditorium, all these children were in school.
And you went to school a half, four, five days a week, a half-day at a time.
The classroom was above the auditorium,
and it was so close to the mountain that you could look right out the window
and see deer walking around, right out from the building.
Again we are back to the milk line.
That man that's running the milk line is a neighbor of mine right now.
[Walter laughs.]
He worked for the hospital at that time.
And you were taken on, on hikes.
You went camping,
A lot of times, you would take a little bag of food.
If you were gonna be out close to mealtime, then everybody had their own picnic lunch with them.
You could walk the road without much trouble.
At that time there wasn't traffic like there is today, and you just walked the main roads.
[Sarah Richards:] And this was a coed activity, both boys and girls?
[Walter:] Yeah, this would be yes, both boys and girls were doing this.
You were taught how to make your own bed.
There would be clean linen twice a week, or more if it was necessary.
These were different nurses.
There was a nurses' home built right to the south of the main, of this main Children's Hospital.
They had their own nurses' home building right there.
This hospital had its own power plant, its own kitchen, dining room.
Even the nurses liked to use the swings.
[Sarah Richards:] Did the nurses stay for a long time or was there a lot of turnover,
where they would quit and new ones would come in, or become ill?
[Walter:] A lot of nurses stayed.
They would marry other employees there and live there,
a lot of the nurses still, that came here as nurses, married somebody and still live here, in the area.
There was a lot of patients that came here, when they were cured,
they went to the nurses' training course at [?], on the grounds, and then they stayed here as nurses.
Some went to other tuberculosis hospitals throughout the state to nurse.
But a lot of them stayed here.
And like I say, a lot of them still live here.
They came from different parts of the state and they still live here, in the area.
[Sarah Richards:] Were these girls or boys?
[Walter:] That's probably, probably girls and boys both there.
[Sarah Richards:] Girls would walk around without tops?
[Walter:] No, the girls would have, would have had tops.
This is one of the buses... they had at that time that would take children for rides.
Some of these are leaving, been here for the summer.
Some are leaving, going back to Mont Alto, which is five miles down the mountain from here.
They get a train from there to Hagerstown,
and then from Hagerstown they would take another train, to Philadelphia, Washington, Baltimore.
Most would be, most that came in here would be from Pennsylvania,
there would be some from other states, but most all would be from Pennsylvania.
And when you went out on walks you lined up, sort of in military style.
Everybody traveled together.
Raising of the flag, every morning, evening.
The flag went up, or the flag come down.
You were out for the raising and the lowering of the flag,
a lot of different little activities like that to keep your mind occupied, keep you out of other troubles.
[Sarah Richards:] They all appear to be dressed up?
[Walter:] These are children that are leaving.
They've been here for the summer, and they're leaving and going back home.
They're getting on it, boarding the train right now.
Now people who came here like myself that lived, I only lived about 40 miles from here.
My parents brought me and they came and picked me up and took me home.
[Sarah Richards:] That appears to be the end of the film.
[Walter:] Yes, I believe that is the end.